so this is a super super strong
tournament it's only limited
to gms and ims
so we can see the top players here
some of these players i don't quite
recognize
okay maybe some of these i do
oh my madoff's playing
1996's
that is board nick
yeah jigalco
and chicago is 9c that's crazy
wait what just happened
wait the tournament was starting in four
minutes but now it's starting in
about
13 minutes
did we just spend time
also thank you dekunat
saying wootwoot
wait what i'm playing a game oh it
started
wait
oh i have leeches open my phone too wait
ah
for my laptop wait howdy
oh my laptop's open so it ah let me um
include my laptop
wow that started really unexpectedly am
i gonna win by forfeit because my
opponent
is m.i.a
what just happened
yeah this is uh operena
well actually he's from russia but i
think he's
studying somewhere in st louis
oh grad student at the at mizzou i mean
in st louis it's still
morning so
also my opponent is still asleep
i wonder yeah i wonder how many
games in this tournament
people are we're not ready
a good thing i was paying attention
oh should i refresh
i want to refresh and then reset the
clock
even though that's probably not what
what would happen
oh chris rebel deb with a wake up
opponent bits yeah don't cheer too
loudly
i want my opponent to
stay asleep
and there's no there's no button to give
more time so i can't
i don't even have the option of being
generous
a recent video on my clips channel
was titled casually beating a grand
master in five moves
but this is casually beating a
grandmaster
in
like one ply
like one move
so apply is half a move basically
because my opponent's not moving
d4 is too strong i guess
i played d4 and my opponent was lulled
to sleep
oh i feel kind of bad though
i feel like i did something morally
wrong but i just joined the tournament
and
one by forfeit
was it rated
now i'm confused
i shouldn't gain rating for that
back to tournaments
like in rating for that
no i didn't
that's good
even though that was it did say raiden
i would feel bad if i keep waiting for
that
oh i'm in first place too
oh
i wanted to
take a photo of that and tweet it
my oh i'm in first place again okay time
to tweet
first place
okay
by tweet
no i don't like to brag on twitter
at least not too discreetly
okay first place
i feel so powerful now
okay playing oh i played this opponent
before
strong player i beat this opponent
before
opponent seems prepared
i'm kind of prepared to
try and go into e4
also just trying to conserve time maybe
i should have played this i don't know
queen g6
f3 might be coming
i think i might have some queen g3 idea
it's hard to judge i'm still waking up
to
f3 i'd probably just move back
and then go for the attack against g3
f4 might be coming
should be okay if g4 i chop the rook
ooh white's defending everything
c5 is pretty thematic here
whenever f3 is played then c5 makes more
sense
funny looking position
f4 never mind
should d7 it's also b6
b6 bishop a6 is some plan
my worst piece
not super comfy though
at least i have the file pressure
[Music]
this move
idea queen g3 knight f3
i would love to triple pork
with the pin fork
oh matt black man thanks for gifting
trying to stay focused here though
um
this move
actually knight h16h7
okay
a4 queen c oh no maybe queen b5
i'll play d4 eventually
no i got forked
not the end of the world still some d4
ideas
initiative two
[Music]
oh
[Music]
i'm in big trouble here
no it's it's a pin ah
oh i'm so salty
oh
i thought it was actually close to
winning there
with taking in this move oh my knights
pinned
oh it was close though
i was optimistic even around here maybe
i should take
very like tricky game though that's a
fun game
i mean
i
i'm not gonna have too much time to
analyze
uh
i guess i could get like a really quick
impression
oh i was losing most of that game except
here that's a better plan
uh just knight ge4
yeah this is a more normal move
okay
oh playing victoria one
um
let's repeat the same opening
yeah we have the same exact opening so
92 was played last game
if castling i take on h2 it's a nice
trap
ooh so the point is after it takes here
here
g5
get some g5 emotes
uh now i think take some queen g5
if f4 it's made in one
i'm threatening to take and win the
queen
so i think the best move is to take
and then
like with queen or bishop
maybe i take with bishop
just to keep the pressure
develop a bit more
yeah this is very pleasant opening prep
okay i wanted 15 moves i mean why could
play on i think i've had i probably had
games in this position
or not quite
but maybe something similar
i feel like i have a game where f4 was
played
yeah
i have to find that uh
i could probably look up the vod from
this game
may be included in this future youtube
video
uh let's not berserk let's finish let's
finish with at least one win maybe
it's been so long since i've last won a
game
i forget what it feels like
okay still still theory
oh opening trap let's go
bishop h2
and g5 coming it's got those g5 emotes
um
yeah this is already completely winning
because this is checkmate
okay
i like games like that
i just end like that was basically all
preparation too yeah i should give a
shout out uh to casa corley
um
fellow international master also
streamer
goes by casablanca on twitch
he's the one who innovated this uh
bishop d6 line
and
it's had some really nice games
and the main game was against moysenko
which usually goes
that game went like
this um
yeah this game
and like the whole thing was prepped
knight takes before
this beautiful beautiful game and he
plays rook e5
uh sacking the rook for this diagonal
because after takes here
and he won in just such beautiful
fashion
kim ji wanted to mate
anyway so big shout out to casa
but the line we went into was
um just a bit more
a bit more simple just takes some g5 and
um
yeah the final position
oh
so queen g5 wasn't the best move
and white could play on
so apparently i'm supposed to take on e3
which is really cool and then queen g5
and then win the rook that's cool
okay so i'm white i'll play a london
ooh uh
i guess i'll mix things up i usually
don't play this move but
let's play it f3
okay
yeah i'm i'm out of theory here
unfortunately
so
you took some great pictures of world
cup oh thank you
yeah it was a fun event to photograph
i appreciate the sub
926 andy
so black can't castle because i'm in the
pawn
i'm feeling i'm already feeling slightly
worse here
i'm preventing knight c4
and probably i just want to play like
bishop d3 and castle
if takes i
probably allow the queen trade
wow e5
i'll take and play knight d5
even play rook d8 first
play knight d5
i have the square i mean f5 might be
coming
one might want to play this takes f5
the knight d6
it's
murky it's weird position because if
castling i still
the taking wouldn't work
or would it
probably wouldn't
castling maybe rook here
wow
knight e4
idea 96 also defending so
if castling i can take and
my queen's not overworked
some idea bishop c5 too
attacking the rook and threatening to
trap the queen
my original plan was to take but this
looks more annoying for black
oh
if i play this i lose a pawn
and there's d6
kind of going all in
there's funny line f5 here here we trade
bishop c4
takes and then i have a xqc thing in the
end
so we're gonna go into something similar
[Music]
chief
i'm in some trouble here
let's just simplify i'm going to be down
the pawn
i'll still get my xqc thing though
the wooden shield
okay
oh i'm not down the pawn
i can't count
oh but i'm losing a pawn
or am i have castling
never too late to castle
upon time too
now i have this move
i'll put a bishop here and then hug the
rook
rook will be my teddy bear
oh i lost a thing
that's okay though idea rook here
ooh
takes
maybe this one
g3 doesn't quite work
give me this move
look at this move
because i want to target that saturn
across the pond three oh thank you
hitting up seven
not sure if this works
oh it doesn't work or does it doesn't
really work
good move
i'm in trouble
go eric go i'm trying i'm trying i'm
trying
i'm in trouble though
[Music]
i'm losing oh it's almost a good game
too
oh i'm kind of sad now
[Music]
oh i blundered so i blundered uh a piece
rook a6 was a really unfortunate move
i mean there's even takes i don't know
why
or no
i think i calculated takes and then i
take here first but then there's rook a1
[Music]
um
i missed rook i broke off take c6 was
unfortunate
good game
though i mean
i felt like i was in control especially
around here
probably should have
not plundered a piece
okay so top 30.
oh i'm uh
i'm exactly in
the middle of the tournament
so 27 out of 54.
do i play a stafford let's play stafford
insist
hey stafford gambit time h3 i play g5
new move
hey
i haven't had too much experience in
this though all i know is rook g8 and g4
um
yeah this is already a new position i
think i'll start with queen here
idea of queen f3 then g4 also
threatening this
there's queen f4
yeah maybe it's not too special
but it's interesting
like the new stafford prep
we'll see how good this actually is i
have this move now i do knight g3
there's also just bishop e6 which kind
of looks nice
complete development
now i can take with rook
so i'm still down the pawn but
got my half open g file
bishop e2 i'll play rook g5
reasonable move
i might have to lose another pawn
i might have to play this actually
an e5
actually knight g4 is kind of
interesting
the idea is i put the rook back on g4
and i play rook g8
and queen g5 so i'm down two pawns but i
want to win this guy
and also target this
wow light's just defending so i can
maybe grab a pawn
oh there's a funny line
what involves
i should start with this
wait a minute
let's start with this hitting the rook
and then idea to take if b3 i play queen
a1
so i want to pawn back still down the
pawn
can i take this
oh no that doesn't work
um
have this move
having the battery maintaining the
idea of queen a1
interesting
put the bishop back
i don't mind the trade because then g2
will be more vulnerable
if this i have to defend
the a5 here
a5 why not
and there's bishop see four
possibilities as well
maintain the rook
oh i got forked kind of but
actually i take
wait
this move
it's still interesting
the knight takes i take the rook
the threat i need to take and win the
pawn
and four i still take
okay
i can take and allow the fork
okay
now it's equal material
time of the time
[Music]
rook wants to be on eight
if rook f8 mates
wow look at this game wow that's a nice
game
oh
and this g5 stafford
uh let's uh i mean probably led to like
slightly worse position but it's still
interesting
um
and got some
yeah still got some play in the end game
it was a nice finish too
because even though
like i'm down upon white has a connect
four
the king
the king was being cornered
um
as nice idea too given
when the rook is in the corner
it has access to the two other corners
to attack the king in the fourth corner
so it's one big square
so if rook here i made
and otherwise i made this way
so i think it's just force made in this
position
yeah
okay maiden four otherwise i'm not
winning
only move
oh i'm playing a game okay
i have to put that on youtube
more stafford worthy content
hey let's play london playing never
enough
oh this opponent has
always
never lost to me
oh we're actually following the game i
played in vegas like 97 bishop here
um this is my round two vegas game
against uh benjamin gladora
i think we're still following it too
[Music]
ladora played b5
yeah rook beat is slightly less accurate
i mean it's still playable though
um
yeah i think when this is played i'll
play b4
interesting i take
i can take and play knight f3
there's some funny idea to like do this
and this and this and this
um
let's be flexible though
okay
and black still has this idea
ooh
[Music]
let's play this hitting the pawn i do
knight h4 maybe
knight e7 i win this pawn
i don't think f6 was a great move
okay g5 makes sense though
i think i'll play g4
idea this is this
it's risky for black to play this
because it just weakens stuff
um
i do this
i mean i'll do the same thing
maybe b4 just have some resource of b5
oh there's almost a funny idea to take
play this force a king overtake and play
queen f7 to mate
it might actually be a threat
now it doesn't quite work
with king g7
there's another funny idea
um
i want to do funny things
i'll start with this idea maybe to take
and then fork
as king here i win the rook
black avoids it
i'll watch my time too
my knight wants to be elsewhere
lean back i don't know what i'm doing
now
it will repeat once
or not
take
oh my knight wants to be on c5
attack at b6 i
i play a5
it takes i take
it takes
i guess i i take first probably
wow it's getting spicy
take
oh no my okay not my queen
there's a funny line where here here
it's not too bad check
uh i guess i'll take
intense position
[Music]
oh tactics
i take and fork
ricky this move
back
[Music]
i think it's okay
no
we drew
my night get kept getting attacked
how do i win this
is this just just a draw
i was up a full night too i repeated i
didn't mean to repeat
i guess i have to play f4 takes f5 no
maybe that was my best chance to win
man i want a game
is like winning
okay final position
wow it's just a draw that's crazy
it's a draw the whole time
i'd see two
g4 only winning move
how is g4 the only winning move
and night oh night a one
i'm so confused
i think i understand but
that's crazy that's hard to find in
this game
with no time left
that was a fun game though
i mean i felt good about my form
okay playing funny chess
ooh maybe we'll have some funny lines
okay
oh london
um i have to remember my prep
opponent is just doing funny stuff
yeah this is like a reverse queen's
gambit accepted
which i don't really play
in this move
i do eventually want to play this
i can get the bishop hair
um
whoa it's lafong what's up lafong
i appreciate the raid
for the lafonger is just joining
i'm playing a strong blitz tournament
i'm trying to stay focused
but shout out to the fong someone use
the left hand command
la fong
[Music]
okay i'm i'm actually under pressure
here bishop b7
i want to play this this this
the thing is even though i'm
underdeveloped
i have the only light squared bishop on
the board
and it could be maybe used for
destruction of the white king side
problem is knight b5
maybe this move
i do this
that e5 is probably coming
i'm down a lot of time
okay we might end up trading everything
play b6
idea this
you might want to play bishop ea2 never
mind
so no more light squared bishop
still ideas of this maybe even h5 at
some point
interesting
this move
there's bishop f8 so i'm not getting
back ranked
hoping for some queen g3 tactic at some
point
and there's a5
kind of weakening but
preventing b4
so 94 would just trade
it's a fair move okay let's play this
if we trade roxy it comes
there's a target
b3 there's some a4 idea
even 94 eventually
maybe 94 to start
with the bishop
a4 next
on the idea bishop f4 here
almost works let's play a4 first
oh
takes takes
spending too long
i'll play on instinct
um
the pawns should be on dark squares
restrict the bishop
i got tricked
i forgot my knight was hanging
oh no
muslim
tricks
almost
actually kind of tricky
and well played
oh very well played
okay i resign
ah
oh that was rough was f2 winning
f2 rook f5
not quite
what to do
good game i just blundered at night i
didn't see this idea
i thought i could just do stuff and my
knight was
usually defended
not after bishop b4 so
what's my score
oh i'm 50
i've kind of alternated
i'm three and a half out of seven
which i feel like is maybe kind of
average
uh playing coupon okay i'm also really
close to my peak blitz rating
which uh
i'm not sure if i passed it this
tournament
bishop d3
i did study this at some point like in
preparation for hikaru
uh recur bishop here maybe
the pawn belongs here
i can play queen c2 and not worry about
knight b4
i remember this idea too
[Music]
so preventing bishop f5
um oh i'm a bit too slow here
move back
there's some 95 ideas
f6 looks
wrong
the block's a bishop
that's still interesting
queen e5
keeping pressure
uh the bishop's rerouting
the time's gonna be important because
this could be a long game
e-file is the only open file wow b5
i take
when upon
bishop d5 coming
c7
some idea of this and then double
[Music]
okay so i'm up upon
still takes work
that's my plan maybe bishop here
just chill
oh
rook is trapped
wow that's dirty
i have no swear to my rook
okay i have to play this
ah there's bishop g2
[Music]
or not
this
it's not over i have some queen side
play
for this
the pawn should be here
back
i want to make a pass pawn
i'm in trouble
this move
no that loses
play this first
i'm losing this
where am i
a king d2
[Music]
still fighting
i actually don't know what's going on
roxy at bishop d2
[Music]
some hope
if i need to queen with me chuck
i think i'm winning now
hello to utah
what
wait what happened
i
wait
oh
we three-folded here
it was repetition oh no
oh i had four seconds i was close to
flagging but still
i wanted to play for a win do you have
any dubious but interesting ideas
against the english
oh
oh man
that's kind of tilting man i mean i
probably should have lost that at some
point
i force mate
wait
sure i don't miss the next game
oh my i had made in four
one
oh bishop h6
yeah it was confusing with the queens
and the bishops
wow
okay at least i didn't lose i mean this
graph was kind of scary i was minus nine
for many moves
okay
what a game
so that's another draw
i was confused at that the end there
man
dubious ideas against english
um
i'll have to think about that
now i enjoy a reverse grand prix but
it's not so dubious
but still aggressive
okay
there's really no time to like recover
after these these games
just have to move on to the next one
so we have this line again
so with knight f3 i play
bishop here
and knight bd7
also thanks for subbing uh reptile
monster
um
a5 first
discourage the minority attack maybe
even b5 here
and magic harry
yeah it's hard to address subs when like
in these games
my c pawns attacked
i play this
and
bishop g4
might want to take
the queen is useful here because it
prevents 95 i have three
attackers on e5
now i think i take and play queen d6
interesting
oh it's not blunder
there's g6
there's takes in queen e6
of here it takes pawn would have to take
i think is a good transformation i mean
the knight might come in
i have this move
obstructing the queen
in here then there's f3
and f6
i want to shift my rooks to the e-file
okay not sure what else to do here
just want to attack somehow
[Music]
h4 it's not h7
i don't want to trade queens
okay pongo's marching
this move
it knight's coming to d4 i'll move back
to d7
i might want to sack on h3
between d4
um
it's hard to calculate
rely on intuition though
this knight's a bit out of play
and i'm relying on the prospect of the
rook lift
ah there's rook
two coming
i take first
rookie six
gotta move faster
oh there's rock h2
ouch
[Music]
this is not good
not what i wanted
d4 i take it
maybe winning c5
oh
i don't have enough time either ah
and i was getting mated
the game though
yeah i think i've
i was a bit over ambitious with stocking
um
another interesting game like all my
games have been like really hard fought
um felt like i was almost coming back
engine yeah engine says it's close to
equal here i was better
i had no time though
uh c5 first
i regretted not playing d4 like sooner
this is still equal
oh because i can force i can win the
pawn with c2 intakes
um was the sack good the sack was
probably terrible yeah
stockfish insulting me for this
i just had to maintain the tension and
play quickly
like it's really good structure when
there's a pawn here because then my c
pawn oh it's a game starting game starts
in zero seconds okay
uh well we move on
oh playing a low rated player wow
interesting let's play this
when it was hoping i pre-move e3
now i think i play this
like a reverse trompowski but
i'm getting tempo on the bishop
i kind of want to play h4 here
f6
what is this
there's also queen d3 threatening this
i think i'll play queen d3
already envisioning like some crazy trap
things
probably don't work
although there is this move
it's actually a cool move
the point being uh bishop g6 i take and
the h pawns pinned
i'm also threatening g4 so g6 i trapped
the bishop
um yeah i think i play g4 here i'm crazy
opening
not your typical london
yeah now black has to suffer with the
structure
and there's queen b3
there's this move
i am moving a little bit too slowly
though
[Music]
um
just this move
i'll build my london triangle
slightly delayed triangle
that's good move e3
bishop probably wants to be here
because then i have some threat of uh
bishop g6
i want to play f3 everything on the
third rank
f3 is maybe
playable actually don't see anything
wrong with it
because takes takes
all my things are defended
i move back i win the g pawn
such a weird opening
it just keeps getting weirder too
[Music]
now i want to take attack the knight
still have this resource
knight's almost trapped actually okay it
has moves but
it has to move to sad squares
oh knight moves and queen covers g6
i want to play this and this
is this sort of position it's all about
uh
getting the pieces in exploiting the
king
always play f3 yeah
i think you board uh bird person
clubbing with prime
i'm allowing this
there's a funny line where i play kingy
too
[Music]
let's do it
yeah this i should not have allowed this
but it's kind of funny
because the queen is in my crib
now wow i can take
it just keeps getting weirder and
weirder and weirder my d4 i take
and my my minor pieces cover the
infiltration squares
i mean there might be some weird
perpetual
knight of two i play this i think
threatening bishop g6 to win the queen
wow side castling what is this
i threatened i could play this fighting
maiden one
why not
i'm so confused right now i have this
move too
this actually looks stronger almost
traps a queen
take
there's almost some on passantme
potential
oh it's a free queen
okay
g5 resigns let's go
that was such a funny game
i guess on passantimate is hard to
orchestrate
i was envisioning something like
uh check here
check here and then check on check but
you could run
what a game
like these ideas like this queen
the ideas you don't see too often queen
d3 to h3
uh pin the thing to the thing
and then g4
and then like g5 being met with f3
and then just a pawn party
okay
oh six ongoing games
um
and then
yeah then i just sacked my c pawn
and then had this kind of nice
construction
and then
yeah my king was remarkably safe on e3
that was a cool game
so my peak blitz rating is 26.59
currently 26.52
um
oh there's 13 rounds
this is going to be rounds
smashed avocado bell joyosa mozzarella
mvp parmesan vinaigrette bakery forest
ham and many more at subway can i get an
eat fresh eric
oh i appreciate the
the subway advertisement sub
[Music]
um
eat fresh
okay let's play chess i'm playing
grandmaster
um
yeah so this is still prep
in general i delay playing c6
with cases where i might play c5
defending the pawn
and then
i think c6 and then knight g4 is a
typical plan
just want to trade pieces
threatening the fork
there's a funny line where i play f6
which might actually work
because i lose i lose a piece on g4 but
then i win it back along with a pawn
otherwise i win the pawn anyway
so h3 might be a move
oh bishop 7 is a move but then i take
take
this interesting line
if i win
upon
opponent going for compensation
[Music]
of this move
and
the line i'm looking at queen d2 doesn't
quite work though
two
i should probably just defend
the defendant move quicker another fake
coming
b2 is still hanging
okay
i have d4 here
the d4 now here i play this
or even i take
but this traps tonight i think
there's knight d1
kwok h3
the king always has refuge here if this
happens
oh there's this threat too
rookie seven
uh
i think opponent was expecting me to
take
and just kind of pre-move knight c5 okay
that worked out nicely
okay
wow
not the type of opponent i would expect
to beat so quickly but uh
i guess it was a nice little opening
trick
and queen e2 looks natural like attack
the thing
i was trying to provoke the trade
but uh
okay now i have some time to
relax was maybe one of my quickest wins
um
yeah queenie two's just a blunder
so yeah it's more common to take and
i
think i've had similar positions on the
chest before
at least like after knight
g4 apparently rookie 7's slightly better
anyway that was nice clean game let's go
back
um
oh almost wait what's my
hey i'm at my peak
so i'm uh
i checked my peak right before that game
so i'm 26 59 again
now
i'll need to win the next game to set a
new peak
playing someone around my rating
it's a long username
yeah i'm sticking with london this
tournament
um c5
so go into benoni
in honor of lefong's cat
so
preventing b5
usual ideas of this stuff
e6 might happen or e5
e6 maybe i taken when a pawn
okay rookie one is natural
yeah there's a lot of moves i can play
here which are just kind of thematic for
the position
you bring the knight to c4
wait can i do the math black has four
attackers i only have two defenders
well maybe i'll play this first
try and provoke knight d7 then take
or even 97 i win the d-pawn
e7
[Music]
this could get very very messy
i'm not sure about this but like the
center is about to explode
also a6 just traps my bishop and
oh i have bishop c6
yeah it's just getting messy though
oh if i take take i get forked on c2
[Music]
yeah this is probably a bad decision
but it's still interesting
attacking the bishop
a lot of the tension here might want to
play e5 if i get the chance
i should start calculating like takes
takes
we trade queens on d1 i lose b7
i takes
i'll take first and go for c3
it's also bishop g5
bishop g5 is kind of interesting
because now bishop c4
there's an f7 potential
[Music]
fc3
you just bishop back
support the knights
at five i can move back
i probably want to play c3 next
just a very confusing position here
trying to keep the tempo
right here i think this is okay
then rook d8
maybe in queen b3985
oh maybe i just take and simplify
yeah this position is nice
appreciate the bits from adfost
something about traxler
ooh
let's play this in rook here
maybe even no let's play this
and f5 i taken bishop e6
hmm
i don't really want to trade queens
that's very pleasant position now
i was fighting bishop h6 there
um
there we go
[Music]
okay that was pleasant
hey new peak
26 65.
let's go
that's a nice game too
like position got really weird in the
middle game
with somehow i
found some nice moves like bishop g5
bishop d4
there's a nice combo
okay
there's one more round right
it's going to be the final round that
was around 12.
next round starts in 10 seconds
i think you mvp at life
okay
oh and add foss said oh just how the
great oh no my queen in the tracks are
ooh
[Music]
okay let's play
oh i play a traxler no let's play a
stafford
stafford gambit maybe
i had this earlier
oh so this yeah this is a move that
carlson played against me
very respectable move
e4 bishop before
unfortunately
this is just a bit worse for black
because i'm down the pawn
i've had this before like it's still
somewhat playable
two month anniversary apparently yay yay
thank you unbuilt sphere smash to your
new peak rating
oh yeah yakshimash
appreciate that
my name is borat
bishop g4 here
i have some nice pressure now
i'm down the pawn but
that's the nature of this sort of gambit
line
thank you wonton
splashdown what kind of shoes are you
wearing right now
uh
i'm wearing non-shoes
i'm wearing socks
but yeah no shoes for now
enough for
just queen d7 leaving all the tension
i'm just trying to make my opponent
think more
and i take and
okay it simplifies a little bit there's
this
maybe queen each four [ __ ] by five
there's still this move
i just want to take and double the pawns
wow opponent allows me
it's still playable
my queen here some idea of bishop f4
i might want to play g6
just restricting both minors
and even f5 then queen b3 is coming
there's 97 too
about this move queen g5 just defending
stuff
and then maybe the stuff
oh what to do
i guess i just push the h pawn
king h1
that moves interesting
yeah i didn't want to go into this
bishop g6 line
okay gotta play faster
as long after takes queen b3 i take on
g3
some queen d2 idea
[Music]
yeah i'm in some trouble
wait rookie six
wow
wow i'm in big trouble
my queen has no way to defend
[Music]
all played
please take c7 please
there was my position i played well
to do
it was my king okay
oh
that was a cool game though
like very hard fought
i until after queen b3 i'm in trouble
like my queen was just misplaced
it was pretty cool how white managed to
like just deal with the double pawns
is that it is that the tournament
yeah that was round 13 of 13.
i finished with 7
out of 13
maybe enough for top 20.
that was fun though got to play a lot of
like strong i mean all my opponents were
like items or gm's
so
i felt like i was in decent form maybe
could have done a little bit better
um
this last game
[Music]
last game i felt like i was pushing
yeah things kind of went
they went downhill for me and uphill for
whites pretty quickly